fifty-three percent of the energy
consumed in Europe is imported in third
countries namely Russia if the
dependence that comes with a big price
tag 400 billion euros and so Europe
wants to build an energy union the
objective is a secure and diversified
supply and develop renewable energies on
the eve of the cop21 in Paris the Energy
Committee put forward a series of
measures this week the spotlight was
also thrown on the aviation industry and
employs more than 5.1 million people in
Europe and represents two-point-four
percent of GDP at the Brussels many
plenary mvps adopted a resolution to
guarantee fair future competition whilst
upholding security and employment
standards the Commission is expected to
incorporate these proposals within the
aviation package by the end of 2015 a
busy week for the economic and Monetary
Affairs Committee hosted both during
diesel bloom and Mario Draghi the
Eurogroup president's focus was on
Greece in particular the insolvency of
households and non-performing loans that
all threaten the stability of the
country's banking system the President
of the European Central Bank Mario
Draghi assured on Thursday that the ECB
is ready to take further action if the
inflation outlook weakens relocation
refugees finally kicked off the first 30
left Greece for luxembourg at the
beginning of the month at the valletta
summit in malta the president of the
european parliament martin schulz called
for a long-term approach with African
partners the european parliament has now
allocated 2.3 billion euros in trust
funds for both Africa and Syria spits in
candid art the processor help choose a
president of the european commission was
the success of the european elections
2014 any Peas now want to official eyes
that experiment by amending you
electoral law the text voted on by any
Peas at the plenary on Wednesday also
foresees the introduction of mandatory
thresholds and making it easier to vote
from abroad however no agreement was
reached a restrict parity on the lists
or over low-res of a teenage
I